bayern wie aus dem bilderbuch trachten
traditionen und eine beeindruckende
landschaft bayern ist zu einem mythos
geworden und zum beliebtesten reiseziel
in deutschland touristen lieben land und
leute märchenschlösser und die
bayerische lebensart samt der
dazugehörigen lederhose die lederhosen
sind toll und sehen gut aus vor allem
die mit dem riemen in der mitte ich weiß
nicht genau wie die heißen aber die mag
ich die sie in toll aus daher ist so
eine schöne gegend die landschaft die
straßen und häuser
die menschen hier sind
wald gebirg und königs traum mythos
bayern heißt die ausstellung im kloster
ettal die die sagenhafte geschichte
bayerns erkundet verschiedene exponate
zeigen wie zunächst jäger und holzfäller
die unwirtliche landschaft kultivieren
die erzeugnisse des waldes werden zur
lebensgrundlage der bau holz als
wichtiger werkstoff beim bau und in der
kunst
[Musik]
erst mit der landschaftsmalerei des 19
jahrhunderts werden bald sehen und
gebirge zu einem sehnsuchtsort im mythos
bayern verbindet sich der alpenraum mit
einer besonderen lebensart und diese
verbindung ist perfekt weit über
deutschland hinaus vermarktet worden und
dadurch sind bilder generiert worden die
bis heute in den köpfen der menschen
fest verankert sind
die königs dynastie der wittelsbacher
fördert das entstehen eines bayerischen
nationalgefühls bergpanoramen volksfeste
in tracht und bierkrüge werden zu
symbolen bayerns die trachten allen
voran die lederhose werden als
nationalkostüm verordnet bayern wird zum
idee
mit dass bayern ist eine schöpfung von
menschen der war also nicht von göttern
für andere mythen wie es beispielsweise
behauptet wird das einzige was nicht von
den menschen kommt sind tatsächlich die
berge geht wieder die große rolle
spielen alles andere kommt dazu dass ist
die lebensart das ist der schuhplattler
der von einem einzel tanz tanz sozusagen
von vielen weiterentwickelt wird das
sind die königsschlösser ludwigs des
zweiten die dem ganzen die krone
aufsetzen
ludwig der zweite befeuert den mythos
bayern bis heute weil es das vielleicht
berühmteste bauwerk bayerns errichten
schloss neuschwanstein mit jährlich fast
1,5 millionen besuchern ein
touristenmagnet
genau wie das oktoberfest rund sechs
millionen gäste feiern jährlich ihre
vorstellung von bayerischer lebensart
ebenso bekannt in aller welt bayerische
autos und die fußballer des fc bayern
münchen
deutsche rekordmeister mit fans auf der
ganzen welt
[Musik]
mit dem trubel um die bayerische
lebensart kann dann hier nur wenig
anfangen
auf den almwiesen in der nähe von
garmisch partenkirchen die urigen bayern
ziehen sie hier auf die pfeiler 1 zurück
beim berühmten bayerischen bier kann man
hier erleben was den echten bayern noch
ausmacht
[Musik]
in vielen gasthöfen im tal treffen
touristen und traditionen aufeinander
alte bräuche wie das schuhplatteln
werden hier am leben gehalten und in die
nächste generation weitergegeben
trotzdem sind besucher aus aller welt
willkommen ob heimatgefühl oder
sehnsuchtsort der mythos bayern wird von
einheimischen und touristen am leben
gehalten
[Musik]